well time to play ball you know major
league baseball has been in action for
over a month now but
today marks the return of minor league
baseball and our very own las vegas
aviators are taking flight tonight
taking to the diamond for the first time
in over a year of course the pandemics
shut down minor league baseball all over
the country last year our hector mejia
inside the las vegas ballpark looking
pretty comfy out there hector ready for
some action
i sure am and the sun feels amazing and
it feels
really nice to be back you know we've
been taking you around the facilities
all morning long and this pool here
overlooking the field is one of the many
things
that makes the ballpark unique it makes
the team stand out as well
joining us live we have mr jim gemma
here with the las vegas aviators
good morning to you sir exciting day for
everyone
hector uh it's great for you guys to be
here it's a great day for minor league
baseball
for the fans of southern nevada and for
our players to finally get between the
chalk lines tonight and for the whole
industry of minerally baseball to play
what are we playing against tonight
who are who are we going to beat yes uh
well we have a six game series against
sacramento rivercats uh
triple affiliated san francisco giants
so be we're aaa the a's so
be the a's and giants for uh from now
until tuesday
and all minor league teams are starting
with a bit of a different schedule is
that right
yeah we're still got a really good
schedule 120 games
60 at home 60 on the road but we're
going to do this year play six game
series
uh from thursdays through tuesdays have
every wednesday off
the theory is to have the team basically
stay in the same city for a week so
uh hopefully that that will help you
know things uh in in that nature
so jamie you're involved with people who
work here with the players with the team
with really
everyone what are you hearing from them
after being on pause for a whole season
everybody's extremely excited our
players are so happy to get back in here
they're
uh you know most of our guys were with
the major league club in spring training
they're at the alternate site in
stockton so
past two or three days these guys have
played actually a couple of them already
went up to the
oakland a's because of injuries and what
have you but
our players we have a really good team
on paper so again these guys are just
excited after a year off
most of these guys didn't get a chance
to play last year some of our guys were
at the alternate site last year and had
some major league time but
ultimately they just can't wait for the
705 first pitch
and for those who are wondering the
stadium the ballpark will only be up to
half capacity yeah i mean we're uh we're
really happy to be at 5 000 at this
point in time the way things looked uh
you know two three months ago with
really what's helped is the you know the
vaccine roll out that's the key to the
whole thing
we go on a long road trip after may 25th
so
we'll come back june 10th and uh you
know everybody knows what could happen
on june 1st uh
hopefully we'll meet all those you know
thresholds and we'll just take it from
there but
we're happy to get 5000 in here tonight
i don't know about you
but i'm ready for the ballpark food yeah
absolutely we have great food out here
psc does a great job
everybody involved with the las vegas
ballpark it's it's first class
all right so again they have uh the
tickets for tonight are all sold out so
i'm just going to sit here and wait
until it's 705
pm or until they kick me out
reporting live hector mejia 8 news now
back to you guys